some parameter row which I'll take to be
positive but basically everything I say
you can think of it being negative
awesome and the basic definition is that
the Gaussian noise ability of a subset
of RN is just the probability that both
of my Gaussian vectors land in that set
this is a pretty simple notion but it
turns out to be quite useful so in
particular relevance to this week it has
applications in approximate E and in
testing I'll say a little bit more about
the application to testing a bit later
but I mean these are just some examples
of course it's been applied to many
other things now the basic question that
you can ask about this definition is
what sets have higher annoy stability to
other sets and there's a very nice
answer to this question do borel which
is that of all the sets with a
particular volume half-spaces have the
largest nguoi stability and maybe i'll
just go back to the previous slide just
for a second for the people that walked
in to say what the noise ability is
because otherwise nothing else will make
sense the gal see no stability of a
subset of RN has the probability that
two correlated Gaussian vectors both
land in the set ok and the theorem is at
half spaces have the largest no
stability so here's the formal statement
let's take a minute to parse it so for
every subset of RN I consider a prime
which is a subset of the same volume but
it's a half space and then the statement
is that the noise stability of a is
smaller than the noise ability of a
prime and just to be absolutely clear
what I mean by a half space is a set of
this form X in RN such that X dot a is
less than B so basically a linear
threshold set
okay now what are the main things that I
want to do today is to give you a new
proof of this theorem which is I think
it's somewhat simpler than the original
proof due to Burrell and then also one
nice thing about the proof is that it's
going to give us a little bit more
refined information about the inequality
so in particular it will help us to
characterize the equality cases and also
say a bit about the near equality cases
all you means galcen yeah the Gaussian
measure right so the when I say
probability of AI mean probability that
X is an a or probability that why isn't
it because they have this industry I
mean it sort of makes sense to have this
restriction because of asking but if a
is a set that X lands and with very high
probability then of course it's going to
have a large motor stability by my
definitions no it's backwards okay right
so I first of all I just want to restate
the theremin in a way that's going to be
a little bit more convenient so i define
capital Phi to be the usual Gaussian CDF
function so capital Phi of X is the
probability that a one dimensional
Gaussian is more than X and I'm going to
consider this set a lot the set of X in
RN so that x1 is smaller than Phi
inverse of a and the point of this right
this is a half space and it's a hospice
which is perpendicular to the first
coordinate and this threshold here is
chosen so that the half space is volume
a that's what the definition fight tells
me ok and now I'm going to define this
function J there's a probability that
first coordinate of X is so basically
the probability that X is in this half
space and why isn't this half space
right and the point of making this
definition is that I can restate
Burrell's inequality in this form so the
point is that the Gaussian measure is
rotationally invariant so instead of
just considering any half space I can
rotate my house space and assume that
it's permitted consider the coordinate
axis and once I've done that then the
definition of this function J ensures
that this statement is equivalent to the
earlier statement right what I've got
here on the right hand side is
they know your sensitivity of this
particular half space whose volume is
the same as the wine away okay so I
haven't done anything yet but so these
are the new results that I promised so
first of all okay so here's my
inequality right if I have equality so
the first new result is that equality is
only achieve a half spaces of course you
can change a up to a set of measures 0
and it won't change anything so equal to
a half space up to measure 0 and the
next thing is something about almost
equality so I'm going to say what if I
reverse my inequality and add a little
bit of slack to the right hand side so
my set doesn't have optimal stability
but it's pretty close and then it turns
out that it must be pretty close to a
half space okay so what I mean by pretty
close is the Gaussian measure of the
symmetric difference is small on the
right hand side there's some constant
which depends on the parameter row and
on the measure of the set and then in
terms of Delta it's polynomial in Delta
okay we give an explicit form for this
exponent but it's not optimal however
recently there was an improvement to
this due to road and el dad who did two
things so first of all you got the
optimal dependence on row this turns out
to be the optimal dependence on row in
the constant and he also got the optimal
exponent of delta which is a half
however there's still an extra long term
there that we don't know if it's
necessary the strip mines light ruler
yeah so I could put a be here in a be
there and it would still be true yeah so
what that's sort of saying is if I want
to define my noise sensitivity with two
sets I want to maximize our probably the
X is an a and why isn't be then I should
take them to be parallel half spaces and
I'm just going to go through the proof
for one set but really the exact same
proof works you just put in a B for half
of the things
it's just me if this probability is is
just yeah that's a good question on our
own yeah I mean I think I think if it's
if this is really small then you're set
is is almost like little bits of stuff
everywhere right so right yeah then I
don't know it's a good question we only
looked ok so there's a few proofs of
this theorem going on so there's the
original proof which uses air art
symmetries ation in sort of quite a
careful way there's a proof from a few
years ago dude Isaacson and also who
sort of translated as a result that
studio British Mukesh logo on the sphere
and then turned it into a Gaussian
result and more recently there was a
sort of very simple and nice proof you'd
akin to an O'Donnell that doesn't quite
capture the full generality because it
only works four sets of measuring a half
and for certain values of row um and
then i'm going to give another one okay
but before I give the proof I want to
give a little application to testing so
so in this I'm going to talk about
testing Gaussian half spaces so I'm
going to suppose there's some unknown
set a and RN and where we have oracle
access to it so we can query points and
I want to check if a is a half space or
close to a half space so let me sort of
mention that really the the application
is no one really wants to test Gaussian
half spaces you want to test boolean
half spaces and the the problem of
testing bull in half spaces was solved
by am matulef O'Donnell Rubenstein
instavideo but testing Gaussian house
spaces and is an important first step
and it's sort of easier to talk about so
I'm just going to talk about that okay
another the goal of course in testing is
I want to give a randomized algorithm
which if a is a half space it's going to
accept with high probability and if a is
far from being a half space then it's
going to reject with high probability so
here's my algorithm I'm going to sample
endpoints from a Gaussian distribution
and I'm going to take P hat to be my
estimator for the volume of a ok now I'm
going to sample and more points which
are pairs of correlated gaussians and my
criterion for accepting is going to be
I'm going to take this thing which of
course this is just an estimate for the
Gaussian noise ability and I'm going to
accept if it's bigger than this
threshold which is like this is what I
expect the noise ability to be and
they're going to put a little slacker
okay so here's a theorem maybe it
doesn't deserve to be called a theorem
because it's sort of a bit trivial given
what I told you so first of all if a is
a half space then this algorithm is
going to work right and that's obvious
because this is what the noise ability
should be and this is my estimate and if
I put a little bit of slack here and m
is large then it's going to work ok and
now the direction which which actually
requires something is that if a is for
forming a half space and m is
sufficiently large then this algorithm
is going to say no right and the reason
for this is because of the previous
theorem right if a is far from a half
space then the contrapositive of the
other theorem says that a has low noise
sensitivity or at least far from optimal
noise sensitivity and that means that
this quantity at least the expectation
of this quantity is going to be smaller
than this and and so if I take em to be
large enough and then it will be then my
sample will also be smaller so the
dependence on epsilon so this epsilon
squared comes from the square root of
Delta that appeared in the theorem so if
my set is epsilon far from a half space
then it'll have epsilon squared
deficiency in the NOI sensitivity and
then have to take em to be epsilon to
the minus 4 because 1 over square root
of M is the sample error that has to be
bigger than this so that's where my
dependence on epsilon comes from and
this gives a slight improvement on the
result that I told you about before
which required em to be e to the minus 6
and was just a tiny bit more complicated
but not a whole lot so
anyway that that gives an application
about theorem okay so now I'll tell you
the proof okay so remember this i have
this function J that I defined and here
is what I'm going to try and prove to
you that for any function so now I've
done something a little bit sneaky here
which is a used to have an equality
about sets and now I'm changing an
internal inequality about functions just
because that's going to be easier for me
to prove so for any function from RM 201
I claim that the expectation of j
applied to f of X and F of Y is smaller
than J of the two expectations so why
does that give you the original
statement well you just plug and
indicate the functions right so if I set
F to be an indicator function well the
point is that if you look at what
happens when i plug in 1 and 0 2 J right
so Phi inverse of 1 is plus infinity and
Phi inverse of 0 is minus infinity so if
i plug in 1 1 then i just get one and if
i plug in either coordinate to be 0 then
i get 0 right and so what happens here
on this left-hand side if i plug in
indicators is i just get the expectation
of one on the event that both of these
guys line it in a right so you see that
these two are really the same thing okay
right so there's one more ingredient in
the proof so here's I've just rewritten
the inequality I'm going to define this
funny operator P sub T or a set of
operators for every T bigger than 0 I
have P sub T acting on functions p sub T
of F at X is given by some formula so
the formula is important but not for
today so I only need to know two things
about this formula today first of all if
i plug in T equals 0 then this term is 1
and this term is 0 and so I've just left
with PT of f at x equals f of X right
and on the other hand if i plug in T
equals infinity then the other thing
happens right this is 0 and this is one
and so I just get a constant function
which is equal to the expectation of the
way so this PT is doing some sort of
interpolation from the original function
down to a constant function okay
now I'm going to look at this funny
quantity for some reason expectation of
j so that's like this thing except
instead of f and f f of X and F of Y i'm
going to plug in PT of F right now the
point of considering this thing is now
if i plug in T equals zero then I've
just got the original thing and if i
plug in T equals infinity then I've got
this thing on the right-hand side and
now the punchline of the proof is that
this thing is increasing in T right
let's and then get the inequality so
let's check that it's increasing in T i
define these V and W and I'm going to
differentiate this quantity and now the
point is that everything is very
explicit right J is some explicit
function that I can write in terms of
some integral and this has an explicit
formula so I can just actually
differentiate this quantity apply the
chain rule integrate by parts when I get
some answer ok so what's the point of
this answer well this is some non
negative constant this e to the
something is strictly positive and I've
got a norm so this is non-negative and
that's the proof modular some calculus
ok so there's at least two sort of
suspicious things in the proof the first
one is I have this thing about sets and
then I change it into this thing about
functions and it just so happened that
the thing about functions that I change
it into had this weird proof for you
differentiate in teen something's
positive right so so I want to explain
two things first of all what does it
mean to go from the set statement to the
function statement and secondly why
might you expect this differentiating in
T to actually give you anything ok so
the first one what happens when you go
from sets two functions and so if you
remember back when i went from the set
thing to the function thing the first
thing we did was to show that the
function one implies the set one when
you plug in indicators right so what I
want to do now to explain what this
functional statement means I'm going to
go the other way and show you that
actually you can prove the inequality
about functions from the inequality
about sets in one dimension higher ok so
the way I'm going to do that is I'm
going to assume i have a function and
i'm going to define a set right so I've
given a function from RN to 0 1 and I'm
going to define a set which lives on RN
plus 1 and it's basically well it's not
quite the sub graph of the function but
it's the sub graph of Phi inverse
composed with the function right so here
X is an RN xn plus 1 is an R and this
point is going to be in my set if xn
plus 1 is smaller than Phi inverse apply
to f of X I have a picture in a couple
slides let's work out a couple things
about this set so what's the volume of
this set well if this point is in the
set then what does that mean it means xn
plus 1 is smaller than Phi inverse of F
at X right the probability of this thing
conditioned on X is just f of X right
that's what Phi inverse does for you and
so this is just the expectation of it so
am I set the volume of the set is the
expectation of F and it might not be you
might be able to guess by now that the
noise sensitivity of this set is going
to be the expectation of this thing that
appeared on the left hand side
expectation of jf in X F of Y basically
from the same reason as before right
what does it mean for X to be in the set
and why to be in the set well XM plus
want us to be smaller than this and yn
plus 1 has to be smaller than that and
now if I conditioned on x and y then
this was just the definition of Jay so
that's why Jay is defined like that and
and so you'll see that this function on
equality really is just the set
inequality but boosted up one dimension
and okay so hopefully that explains the
first mystery which is why this why
going from sets the functions is not so
unreasonable okay right so so I just
have this little extra thing so let's
prove the functional inequality from the
set inequality right so here's the thing
that was on the left of the functional
equality and I said that that was just
the noise sensitivity of my set a sub F
by the set inequality that's smaller
than the noise sensitivity of the
half-space with the same volume and then
by what's above this is just equal to
this right so here i have the functional
inequality from the side of evil
now the second mystery is now that I
have this inequality why should I expect
to define this thing in terms of T and
differentiate and it should be no
negative okay so let's look at well we
have this way of viewing the functional
inequality in terms of the noise
sensitivity of sets so let's see what
happens to those sets when I apply a
piece of T so I just picked some
function here and here's the set a sub F
right and now when I start applying p
sub T so here's T equals zero point zero
one and T equals zero point zero two and
as you make it bigger then this site
gets smoother and smoother and flattens
out and it goes to a constant function
right and now when I have a function a
set sorry when we function goes to a
constant function and the set goes to a
half-space right because it's a sub
graph of a constant function and so
what's happening here is when I look at
this in terms of sets PT is sort of
smoothing out the set until it turns it
into constant and what we showed by this
differentiation is that as you do this
transformation the noise stability is
increasing and it's maybe not quite so
unreasonable because you expect the
noise ability to be large if there's
lots of bumps and so if you're doing a
smoothing on the set then it's no no I
mean it doesn't this doesn't show
anything but maybe you can believe that
that this is a transformation that
increases the noise ability if you have
an l1 party you can just integrate over
those
no please this one yeah so I'm not doing
anything nearly as fancy as that here I
don't think I'm I'm just saying that
that the inequality that I wrote for the
functions is really just an inequality
about the the sub graph of the function
in one dimension higher so so there's no
there no there's no nontrivial level
sets my level sets are just 0 and 1 I
guess because
I mean so what I'm saying is I have an
inequality about this function and and
what it's really like is is it's just
the the set inequality about this set
which is the sub graph of the function
is that ok so so this idea of having
this quantity that decreases as you make
tea is is of course not our idea and in
fact the exact same p sub T was used
well by many people but most relevantly
to us it was used by bakerella do to
prove the Gaussian isoparametric
inequality which is actually quite
related to this noise sensitivity
inequality it's sort of a limit so it
didn't come from nowhere ok so I just
want to tell you a little bit more about
the function J one thing that you that
happens if you actually do the
computation that I skipped is you
realize that the inequality doesn't just
work for our function J it actually
works for some sort of more general JS
so in particular if j is any function
which satisfies this second derivative
condition so this matrix which looks
like the hessian except it has a row on
the off diagonal this thing has to be
non-negative then you have the
inequality ok and this inequality works
when x and y are real correlated
gaussians so i gave this clock once
before and someone said this looks a lot
like Jensen's inequality and it sort of
does good I mean negative semi definite
I think it's so different and so this
point wise so this is a function right
so point y is negative semi different ok
so Jensen's inequality of course would
say if I got rid of the rows right then
this means the J is concave right so if
i get rid of the rows and this
inequality is true for any arbitrary
Joint Distribution of X and Y so you
know I don't know if this means anything
but but one way to sort of look at this
this theorem is to say if I am allowed
to relax the constraint on the concavity
of j as long as I put some constraint on
the Joint Distribution of X and Y and it
seems to be quite special that x and y
have to be real
gassings doesn't work if you take some
arbitrary distribution with correlation
right it's not true no for example
bullion's is not true it's fairly
symmetric no because so for example if I
so these have to be Galus tints of unit
variance so if i take gaussians are the
different variants then you get a
similar inequality but with a different
normalization yeah you can do a bit more
general than gaussians so for example
they do show that you can take it to be
some distribution of log concave things
but definitely you can't do anything you
wants it is this yeah some sub
conditions okay so one thing that I
don't know is if this condition means
anything right i mean it's not it's not
that the function is concave and i've
never seen it before and as far as i
know it's only uses to show this
inequality so i don't know if that's
interesting one thing about our function
J specific function that we defined is
that it's the smallest function which
satisfies this inequality um yeah I
don't know if that's interesting either
okay so yeah that's a good question so
our function J had certain boundary
conditions right I told you its value at
0 0 0 1 10 and 11 right so of all
functions which satisfy this inequality
and have those boundary conditions our
function is point-wise the smallest so
if i have any other function satisfying
those then our function is smaller than
that point wise
you mean this this inequality yeah no I
don't think so I think you have to go
through the proof good to see that
because so so it would be so the
statement that i just said would be true
if the left hand side where indicators
but on the other hand if i replace day
by something that's bigger than both
sides get bigger so yeah okay so here's
a plot of j just for fun this is one row
equals point one and as you might expect
from the previous slide when i make grow
to be bigger than this gets more and
more like a concave function so okay so
what LeDoux showed is that you can have
a so you need to be a can't be any mark
of all but it has to be diffusion first
of all if it's a diffusion and it
satisfies this so i don't think i don't
think the eigenvalues enough i think it
has to there's this black ray emery
condition about dimensioning curvature
which implies as an eigenvalue gap so if
it satisfies that condition then you're
going to need quality but
that I said something about log concave
things a bit before so that's how you
get low concave fun distributions okay
so we're back at the beginning of the
talk I said that our proof tells you
about the equality in near equality
cases so I want to say how that happens
right so here's the claim that if F is
the indicator of some set and I have
equality in my inequality than a should
be half space right so this was what
came up from the proof of the other
thing I had this thing that depends on T
and I differentiated it and I claimed
that you get this formula okay so and
then these are okay these weren't
important before but they're going to be
important now VT and WT in the formula
are given by Phi inverse composed with
PT ok so now remember this equality is
basically saying that this thing at T
equals 0 equals this thing at T equals
infinity now the only way that could
happen is if the derivative is always 0
ok so if I have equality then my
derivative has to be 0 well everything
on the right hand side is strictly
positive this is strictly positive
strictly positive except for this right
this thing can be 0 so if I have
equality this thing has to be 0 almost
surely for every two right so fix it t
this thing has to be 0 almost surely so
grab VT of X is grad WTF why almost
surely and another thing about x and y
is that condition on X Y is fully
supported so if this thing is or if
these things are equal to each other
then they have to both be almost really
equal to a constant ok so gravity is a
constant that means that VT is linear
right VT is linear means that PT of F is
Phi composed with something linear BTW
of F is Phi complicit with something
linear and now what you do is you take T
to go to 0 right and if you think about
five composed with the linear function
the only way that I can get this thing
to approach an indicator function is if
that indicator function is the indicator
of a space because half space is a
linear threshold so that implies that if
F is the indicator of something then I
is a half space so I might just mention
right I don't have to put this condition
that F is an indicator of something
right I could ask what are the equality
cases of this inequality just functions
and the answer is that you have equality
if and only if F is Phi composed with a
linear function and half spaces are just
a limiting case of that okay now the
last thing that I want to do today is
show you this this other piece so I
claimed earlier on that if F is an
indicator and I have almost equality in
this inequality then a should be close
to a half space and this is sort of like
the most technical part and I'm not
really going to go into it I just want
to sort of give you a flavor so this is
the fundamental theorem of calculus
write something at infinity of mine is
something at 0 is the integral of the
derivative and now the point is that for
the Equality case I said that this thing
has to be 0 for all T and then these two
things have to be linear and an equal to
each other well so the next the first
thing that we have to do is get a
quantitative version of this right so if
this thing is small then for all T these
things are almost linear and if these
things are almost linear then PT of F is
almost a function in this form right and
you have to quantify that in terms of
Delta and then the next thing that you
have to do is show that if PT is almost
a function of this form then f is almost
a function for that form right and now
the problem with the second dilemma is
that it's not actually true and the
reason is not true is that PT is a
smoothing operator and so f can have
lots of local stuff that disappears
immediately if it's very bumpy and so
you can't actually prove this statement
because it's not true but you can do
sort of special versions of it so for
example if you include the extra
information that F has good noise
sensitivity then this statement is true
but yeah maybe it's not a not go into
that now so
that's all
but this isn't the stability motion was
known with dependence on the dimension
no so there was but i think i think I
result was the first time this thing had
been studied before there's a there's a
limiting case Rebecca beam okay there's
a limiting case of this inequality so I
sort of mentioned at the limiting cases
the Gaussian has two parametric
inequality and so for the Gaussian
isoparametric inequality the history was
a little bit different so it was shown
by a janky fusk romaji fratelli that if
you have a small deficit then you get
something like this with a dimension
dependent constant and the square root
of Delta right and so the history of
that was was that so after that I'll
come on and I showed that you can get
rid of the dimension dependent constant
but you get something that's logarithmic
in Delta instead of polynomial and then
no I think so what we had was like 1
over square root a 1 over log to the 61
of a delta or something in that so
that's right when Delta gross dessert
sorry honey 1 over log 1 over Delta to
some power yeah so going to 0 when Delta
goes to 0 but very slowly right and so
then that was it was it was related to
this work in the sense that we were
studying this sort of same semigroup in
the same general arguments but it
doesn't actually tell you anything
either way then one thing about about
this result that was a little
unsatisfying is that without so like I
said the isoparametric inequality is a
limit of this as Rho tends to 1 if you
don't get the right dependence and row
here you don't get the you don't get the
galaxy result out of this result and we
could only get the right dependence in
row four sets of measure half for some
technical reasons and one nice thing
about this result by L done is that he
has the right dependence on row and so
now you actually get a robustness
statement for the isoparametric
inequality with no dimension with a
constant independent of the motion and
the correct exponent on delta so now the
question is whether you can keep that
dimension independence and get rid of
them square block is that those fruitful
so based on the same argument I'm not so
it's not immediately the same argument
I'm notched to be honest quite sure yet
how they related I'm sorry use this
increasing property that jake onson is
increasing interest if Sophie so he
doesn't afraid he has a mention of
function J so he has a his argument is
based on the stochastic calculus so he
studies a sort of martingale I think it
might be related because I mean if if
you look at what a semigroup is doing
this time stochastic calculus in there
too right we just sort of didn't write
it in that form and it's his proof is
not an immediate rewriting of our proof
in that form but maybe there's a
connection yeah there is one nice idea
that he had which which you can apply
immediately to proof which is that it
turns out that start
the measure of the symmetric difference
is not a very nice thing to do for this
reason that when you apply PT it smooth
things out and the measure the symmetric
difference can become wildly different
it turns out that that there's a
different metric which is quite nice to
use which is the distance between the
center of mass of a set and its closest
hospice and that that's what it makes
well if there's two gaussians then
there's no other correlation oh you mean
you mean not having identity here or I'm
not sure so if you don't know that it
any of the identity i'm not sure if you
have the identity and you have two gal
seems then this is the only correlation
structure unless you turn around a give
and then if you turn our negative than
the inequality reverses but we can still
handle that well for this to be I mean
this has to be symmetrical it's number
two for two variables there's nothing
else right so you can ask for more
variables like what if I have x1 x2 x3
and then I have a 3 and x 3 n matrix
here and then we know a couple of cases
so so for three variables if all of
these things if all of the coefficients
here are non-negative then the result is
still true that half space is maximized
the rest ability on the other hand if I
take the inverse of this matrix and all
of the off-diagonal entries are non
positive then it's also true so so
they're not negative 1 is due to me and
the non positive one is due to the
muscle and isaacson if they're mixed
then I don't know
just a fact if you say one coordinate
does combination oh and in the other one
there is a smaller correlation yeah then
you cannot you can just think about the
smaller correlation supplied with a
function of this under the weaker
correlation is a bangle functionary
stronger correlation so those will in
fact a family of inequalities like that
that a wicked immediate consequence just
by playing sammarco operator in between
so you know so they you know this is
sort of the extreme case but you get the
sort of a convex family of inequality
that you immediately get like that by
playing this map but there are also some
cases when you have multiple gaussians
where it's not true that that half
spaces I mean so if you're allowed to
take different sets here instead of the
same set a way you like to take
different sets and what I said here is
that the best thing to do is to take
parallel half spaces now you can
actually if you take you know this to be
a big matrix with many gaussians here
and you take some to be positive in
something negative then it might be the
case that the best thing to do is to
have half spaces which are not parallel
but I mean I don't I mean I know that
sort of by example but I don't know what
the best configuration is so you still
I think that's good oh yeah I think so
yeah yeah how involved is the structure
part to decode a half space from this
deficit to decode a half space food
facility was abroad you're close to a
close to j okay so what we did okay so
we have this expression right and now
the point is that that I find that this
thing has to be close to linear for all
team so what you can do to find a half
spaces you take T equals one and you
take the best linear approximation to
this function by which I mean the l2
approximation so the right i just take
this guy i look at it so i look at its
expectation and I take the linear
function with that slope and then I take
P T inverse of that and I get my face so
I mean it's sort of fairly explicit but
maybe you wouldn't want to actually do
it